So let us add a couple of layers to our
linear model. Make a multi-layer neural
network uh or a multi-layer perceptron.
We are going to practice a few coding
hygiene while doing that u such as
device placement patch shapes and uh the
use of write last function. Uh we'll
keep it simple. So that means that we
will move some of the monitoring and
visualization parts of the code to a
companion notebook. Okay. So let's
import a few modules. We are already
familiar with this. We are going to use
a data set here fashion emnest. And if
you go to chapter 4.2 in the book uh
there is an explanation on this uh
benchmark data sets that we can try our
machine learning algorithms and compare
them. One of the most famous one is the
amnes data set. And as you can see here
even simple models are now achieving a
very good accuracy. So to make it more
challenging for oursel we are going to
use the fashion data set and this data
set is in the torch vision um library of
value pytor. So we are going to use that
and to try our methods on it. With that
we need to import the torch vision and
some tools within it including data set.
So notice that I included transforms uh
to use the image transformations uh
tools within torch vision such as
conversion to tensor, normalizing the
images and so on. Here we want to uh
work with or specify the device
and the reason is first we will make a
small tiny MLP but then later we will
add more layers. So we may need to use
CUDA or GPU. So for now we will continue
with CPU but in any case if we want to
use the code later we have to uh
determine the device and when we change
it uh we don't want to change the code
accordingly. Okay. So now let us uh
download the fashion of this data.
Downloading the data to uh a data folder
in my root. And here notice that there
is a transformation that basically
converts the numpy
or pil image data to torsch tensor. It
also scales the pixel values from 0 to25
to 0 to1 reorders uh the channel widths
and heights uh transforms it to a
standard format of channel as the first
uh dimension and then height and widths.
In the case of fashion amnest image, it
will become it's a one channel
grayscale. So it will be uh channel one
channel and a 28x 28 square image. Okay.
So let's download the data. So if you go
to the uh root directory, you see that
the data is now available. So the the
train validation split will be we will
uh leave uh about 10,000 uh images for
our validation set and the rest which
will be 50,000 would remain for our
training set. Okay. So we are going to
use random split um and we are going to
use this as a uh generator basically
only uh load data when we need. Okay.
And let's simplify this is the train and
validation data set. And if you remember
the random split comes from the utils
data. Okay. So now we can make our train
loader and the validation loader. So
train loader uh is basically a data
loader. I mean let's look at this um uh
that gets the batches uh here we shuffle
it during the training. I want to reduce
the size of the the train loader to
basically um better utilize GPU because
we are going to do a lot of batch uh use
a lot of batch during the training. We
don't need to do to be that savvy or
stingy on the validation because that's
not really the bottleneck. So I'm going
to actually increase it to emphasize
with that we can uh we can actually
check the code. So let's see we can get
a x and y batch from our train loader
and then we can of course uh print the
shape. I also want to um plot uh one of
these images. So let's do it. So let's
first run this and then I want to
visualize the the first image of this
batch in the x batch. Okay. So to do
that I'm going to use inkshell and here
it takes the x batch zero and uh here uh
remember this is the second so first
dimension is the number of uh batch and
here we the first batch we get 64 images
and the second one is a just a channel
dimension which here is a
one-dimensional channel if you recall
and here one trick is to instead of
doing this just say that squeeze uh
meaning that gave me a a view of the
tensor where we remove the dimensions of
size one. So this way we basically
remove the unnecessary dimension that
don't carry meaningful information and
remember this is a view so we can do the
reverse of this squeeze and go back to
the original view. Okay. So, let's plot
this and this is an image of a shirt.
Okay. So, everything looks good and we
can go on and make the model. Okay. So,
now we want to make the layers. So, we
can get the self dot can introduce self
layers or let's just be more expressive
here and and sequential. It flattens the
input. it um adds a first layer going
from the input to that and let's accept
this. So one layer one reloop and then
last layer I want to add another layer.
So let's add another layer and here and
n linear. So let's reduce this since I'm
adding another layer.
128 264 and another rel and then the
final output here. So notice that the
output is the output of the linear
regression meaning that they will be
real value positive or negative not
necessarily bounded to 0 and one. So
this is actually a logit value. It's not
a soft max value. So remember that
because that will be important in our
later stage. Okay. So now that we have
the architecture, we can write the
forward method and we are done with the
class and here I want to add um function
that uh computes the accuracy of the
network and we can write it as accuracy.
Um so takes the output of the forward
method which like I said uh the logits
and the labels or the y values and it
takes the maximum uh logit value uh that
corresponds to the prediction of the
classification because if you remember
even if you do the soft max on the logit
the maximum value is the same and it
checks if that maximum value is the same
as the label and that's basically the
number of uh true positives and then len
of bread is the number of all uh
predictions. So this is the accuracy and
remember that this should not use no uh
should not use the gradient uh in other
word we we want to disable the gradient
tracking inside this function and
there's a easy decorator that we can
use. So torch no grad. So this way this
function will not track gradients. It
saves memory of course and speeds the
evaluation. Okay. So let's write a
function that trains one epoch. Okay. So
then total loss and uh we want to track
the total ROS total uh number of correct
and total itself which start with zeros
and then for X and Y in the data loader.
And notice that the suggestion already
did uh did sending the tensors to the
device and this is important like I said
when we later we change the device. So
this will be done automatically here. I
want to uh zero the uh the optimizer
first. So this is optimizer and then we
get the output. So let's just call it lo
for the sake of uh clearance. So here
the output of this model will be uh will
have this shape basically the number of
samples in the batch and for the batch
size and has an logic value. So we will
have some criteria here and the criteria
is uh we get this from the uh argument
remember that we write the function in a
way that if we change the loss it
doesn't really change itself. So the
loss can be fed from outside. Okay, it
takes the log and y and then backward
optimizer step. Okay, so let's review
the suggested uh code. I see that the
code is uh independent of the batch size
meaning that doesn't count the number of
correct prediction within a batch that
may have different size right mean when
we are sampling from the loader we may
it's possible that we accidentally get
different batch sizes and even in the
validation or uh in the validation set
if you remember we chose a different
batch size. So let's make the code be
sensitive to the batch size. So with
that going to make a batch size variable
that gets that and then we have to
update the code accordingly. Okay. So
let's see what we have total loss loss
item. So this is a total loss that uh
should consider the batch size. I want
to make this line independent of the
function accuracy. Uh so let's just
write it by hand. Then here we are
returning also the fraction of correct.
Okay. So with the same logic I'm going
to write the evaluate function then we
can train our network. Okay. So the
model is the s simple MLP. We send it to
device. Of course you have to always
remember that the model goes to device.
The criterion is the cross entropy. Here
we are using Adam. the learning rate is
that and let's use what we learned the
L2 regularity and here the L2 regularity
uh is implemented using this option
weight decay and um if you think
basically if you think about this when
you are doing the training during the
training the weight sometimes increase
and the basically using more variable
and when you increase the weight the the
gradient steps are getting smaller
smaller with respect to the weight sizes
the norm of the weight and the weight
decay makes sure that the gradient steps
remain efficient. Uh we can talk about
that during the class time uh with some
maybe geometrical interpretation. Okay.
So weight decay introduces the L2
regularization. Let's train the model
for a small number of epochs. I want to
keep a record of the history. So let's
do that. Then let's populate the values
in the history dictionary. We can also
print it out.
Okay. So now we can run the code and
wait for it. In the meantime, maybe we
can write a function that can visualize
the the last history
and also the train accuracy.
see that both training loss and
validation losses are going down. Their
accuracies are going up and that's of
course a good sign and uh since we are
waiting for this just a review. So what
we were careful about during the code
was the batch dimension preservation. We
want to make sure all operations
maintain the batch as the first
dimension. We want to make sure uh all
of these operations are processing the
entire batch simultaneously. So that's
the vectorization and the shape
transformations that we did over the
images from the data set. Uh of course
device consistency were also important.
we want to move all of the tensors to
the same device either GPU or CPU and
then at the end the uh handling of the
cross entropy loss that averages over
the entire batch by default. Okay, so
the training is finished and we can plot
that and you see that the loss is going
down consistently and accuracy goes up
and uh which shows that it's worth it if
we increase the apo and maybe even uh if
we are not happy if it is plateaus at
some point about 90% of course that
means that our network is small and we
can increase the number of layers. So
let's do that. Why not? We can make a
deeper MLP. Let's just call it plain MLP
for now as a base class that we want to
maybe uh go fancy with it and add some
residual blocks. If we go deep on this.
Okay. So that and let's initiate it and
add the layers. I want to add uh the
arguments of um some of the uh
architectural decision here. So input
dimension is fixed which is a 28x 28 but
we want to have a control over the
hidden dimension and the depth of the
network and of course the output
dimension is 10. So we can can do all of
it from here. Okay. So let's make a a
list that shows the the layers u the
architecture and the activation in each
layer and then we can append to this
link link list and and then uh later we
will uh basically go over the list and
add them one by one in the sequential uh
and end module. Okay. So layers we start
with the first one which is a linear
layer. Okay. So I see the suggestion is
what I want and we go over the depth and
y -
one. So note that I fixed the hidden
dimension for all of the layers. Um this
basically simplifies the shape
management that we are doing here. Okay.
So we have all of these layers and let's
just um knit them together. Okay. So oh
I see that's why we we have the output
layer separate. So actually don't like
the fact that self out is different. So
why not doing this uh we just add that
right? So we have to update forward. So
here notice that uh my input is at 28x
28. And I like to like to make sure the
image is flattened. to do that if x beam
is for example more than two we just uh
basically get a view that is flattened.
So now that we have a a fairly deep uh
MLP let's compare it to uh a equal
equivalent size MLP that has residual
connection. Okay. So with that I'm going
to first write a residual residual block
that I will use it uh just like any
other blocks that sequentially will be
linearly connected. So first let's write
this block which is an NN module and um
for residual block if you remember we
have to say the dimension of the input
will stay the same and here before
jumping I want to write a reminder that
uh in a residual block we have a
residual mapping that has the same shape
of x and basically give us a x plus fx.
Okay so here we want to write the fx. So
for that self of f is a an n sequential
basically a linear relu and a linear and
then we add the x following that. So
because I'm going to
um need this blocks together I want to
add a relu here. So torch relu and then
this. So this way I don't need to write
the relu again and again. And this is a
this is called a post activation design.
And now we can use this in our residual
deep network. So we have a residual MLP.
We try to keep everything similar to
what we had. Notice that I have a hidden
dimension meaning that I have to first
project the inputs to this hidden
dimension and then do the residual on
that. So I need an input layer and that
basically takes in the input dimension.
map it to the hidden dimension just like
before we have the selfnet. Okay, so
notice that I don't have a rel between
the input and the rest of the layers. So
let's rewrite this. Maybe we can instead
of doing this, we add the red and then
now we have this list uh that we need to
of course zip and then we can finish off
with an end layer in here x to the
output. So what to fix here? We don't
need this anymore. Let's skip this for
now. And now we just add this in the
forward. Okay, we are going to use the
the previous functions and um evaluate
and train epoch and then build the the
plane deep MLP and the residual MLP.
Let's increase the depth and send it to
device. So this is the plane and the
residual is deep residual MLP and we
keep the dimensions the same. a similar
capacity. We are comparing apples to
apples and uh the criterion is still
cross entropy and let's just set up the
optimizers for each one of the models
which is again same still apples to
apples and then we can do the training
loop. Let's do it for 80 bucks. We did
it for 10 next time but this one is more
expensive so going to do it for 10.
Okay, so we have the code. Uh we added
the device and looks like it is running
running okay. So the results is here and
as you can see the residual net is
working pretty good uh better than the
shallow MLP. But you see that the the
plain deep MLP is not really working. Uh
and the main reason as we discussed is
is the depth and the way that the
gradient is vanishing. There are ways to
investigate this for for example maybe
we can reduce the weight decay. we can
work on the normalization, the bash
normalization and things like that and
make the deep MLP uh better dealing with
those things. But the main point is uh
when depth increases it will be more
challenging to keep the gradient flow
backward and the richness of data
forward.